avec nous maintenant le good boule le
titulaire de la chair de recherche en
fiscalité finance publique d'université
de Sherbrooke bonsoir Luc bonsoir on va
regarder avec vous un petit peu plus en
détail ce qui a été annoncé aujourd'hui
à partir de quel seuil de revenu les
Québécois ont droit très exactement à
avoir le soutien financier du
gouvernement du Québec c'est
pratiquement tous les contribuables qui
ont doit avoir le montant mais ce que le
tableau va montrer c'est que dans le
fond c'est que les gens qui font en bas
de 50 000 dollars de revenus nets dans
l'année d'imposition 2021 donc c'est pas
dans la prochaine année pour donner des
déposer en 2021 revenus net individuel
tous ceux qui ont pas de 50000 vont
avoir droit aussi 100 dollars ceux qui
ont entre 54000 et 100 000 on va droit
400$ sur entre les deux vont avoir droit
en 400 et 600 quand notre revenu varie
entre 50 000 et 54000 donc une gradation
une gradation un peu mais la majorité
des gens ont soit 400 ou 600 et passer
100 000 on perd progressivement le
montant jusqu'à 104000 où là on aura en
0 et 399 dollars enfin tous ceux qui ont
104000 de revenus nets et plus
individuellement de nos droits à rien
mais on parle de 93% des contribuables
qui ont droit à quelque chose 93
définissez revenu net c'est le revenu
qu'on a totalise tous nos revenus puis
on soustrait là-dedans certaines
déductions comme le Real nos fonds de
pension etc donc c'est pas le revenu
brutaux
parfait donc premier point première
chose à savoir vous avez là les montants
les seuils il y a d'autres paramètres
également à propos de l'admissibilité au
soutien de l'État bon évidemment faites
un résident canadien il faut avoir fait
sa déclaration 2021 et dire qu'on réside
au Québec au 31 décembre 2021 mais il
faut aussi avoir 18 ans mais là c'est au
31 décembre 2022 oui donc ça veut dire
que jusqu'à la fin de l'année tous ceux
qui n'ont pas encore 18 ans si vous
l'avez avant la fin de l'année vous
allez être admissible à ce paiement là
cette fois-ci il y a des petites règles
particulières
au décès
si on vous avait survécu dans l'année
2022 au premier septembre vous avez
droit à ce montant là donc quelqu'un qui
est décédé le 1er octobre dernier il va
avoir droit au montant s'il y a survécu
premier septembre donc la succession la
succession effectivement en cas de
faillite habituellement on fait deux
déclarations dans l'année si vous avez
faite en 2021 faites deux déclarations
là on dit vous avez droit
automatiquement au montant si vous avez
fait de férié en 2021 et dans le cas de
dette fiscale habituellement ce qu'on
fait c'est on dit ben on va le
gouvernement se paye avant de vous
donner un crédit d'impôt dit je récupère
ce que si vous me devez des sommes dans
ce cas-là même si vous avez une dette
auprès du gouvernement du Québec fiscal
le montant va vous être si vous avez
droit bah vous êtes versé Andréane
énuméré les trois mesures de 2022 dites
nous ce que ça veut dire concrètement
l'ensemble de ces mesures qui ont été
versées pour les contribuables c'est ça
et nous pour faire un petit peu
compliqué on a rajouté une quatrième
mesure qui est la mesure fédérale de
Madame freelen donc parce que pour le
contribuable ça rentre aussi dans la
même c'est ça et donc si on regarde pour
un une personne seule vivant seule avec
un revenu net toujours de 40000 dollars
à titre d'exemple si on totalise le
montant qu'en rien n'avait parlé en
janvier de 275 dollars pour les
admissibles au crédit solarité l'annonce
du budget qui a été versé 500$
et en décembre l'annonce convient
aujourd'hui de 600 dollars ça fait 1609$
que quelqu'un autour de 40000 à droite
et ça quelqu'un qui gagne 40 000 une
fois que ça doit payer ses impôts ça à
peu près 33500 dans ses poches de
revenus disponibles donc lui donner 1609
sur 33500 c'est près de 5% de son revenu
disponibles qui est aussi donc c'est
quand même significatif et pour les
catholiques mais là on voit que le
premier faire semain était plus ciblé du
gouvernement du Québec donc on y aurait
pas il y a pas il y a pas droit 80000 il
y a pas droit à la mesure de Madame
schwiller donc on a eu 9 on a 900 si on
gagne 80000 de revenus nets donc on voit
que c'est plus généreux vers les plus
faibles
parce que j'ai encore deux trois
questions à vous poser
parce que quand on regarde tous ces
chiffres là et quand on regarde ce qui
s'en vient au mois de décembre
mais c'était 3 milliards 200 millions là
c'est 3 milliards 500 millions la mesure
solidarité c'était à peu près 750
millions si je me rappelle bien à peu
près 7 milliards dans l'économie en 2022
est-ce que c'est inflationniste bon
cette inflationniste oui et non donc je
peux pas me tromper en disant ça ça va
être déjà ça m'aide déjà en partant mais
dans le temps il faut comprendre des
sources un peu de l'inflation il y a une
partie de l'inflation qui est causée par
une crise énergétique la guerre en
Ukraine
les difficultés d'approvisionnement donc
c'est pas nécessairement dû à la demande
de consommation des ménages donc fait
une partie qui s'explique autrement mais
c'est sûr qu'elle est donnée 3.5
milliards à des dans la poche des
ménages à la veille de Noël il y a une
grande partie de ça qui va se
transformer en demande accrue de bien
services donc la pleine pression
inflationniste mais pour d'autres
ménages ça va simplement servir ceux qui
ont des taux des dettes des hypothèques
à taux variables qui voient leur
hypothèque augmenter il y en a que ça va
servir à faire leur paiement à
rembourser la dette donc c'est en partie
inflationniste est-ce que on devrait
mieux cibler cibler davantage les
revenus
modestes est-ce qu'on aurait pu mieux
cibler aussi oui le premier chèque était
mieux cibler absolument donc le premier
chèque le l'aide du gouvernement fédéral
de Madame Schulen et plus ciblé donc et
cibla des gens qui ont des prestations à
revenus avec des revenus plus modestes
c'est sûr que comme j'ai dit tantôt si
on verse à 93% des contribuables on peut
pas dire que c'est très ciblé si on
avait baissé à simplement ceux qui
gagnent mettons 80000 de revenus nets on
a ou 75000 de revenus net on aurait
peut-être couvert 80 % des ménages mais
ça aurait déjà été un peu plus ciblé
enfin que ça leur écouté soit moins cher
ou soit on aurait pu en donner plus à
ceux qui avaient droit pour le même
montant donc c'est les réflexions qu'on
peut avoir parfait lieu qu'on s'arrête
ici merci beaucoup avec nous ce soir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]